it's delayed that period of time one of
the drugs used is lupron right which
has actually been used to
chemically castrate sex offenders
you know what
i'm not sure that we should continue
with this interview because it seems
like it's going in a particular
direction well you're a medical
professional i am a medical professional
so you don't want to talk about
the drugs that you give to kids or
again
i'm a physician and i use medication
you're choosing exploitive words
drugs i guess i'm choosing a chemical
guys were those in a dictionary that's
not a correct term for puberty blocking
i could like look it up on my phone but
i'm pretty sure if i looked it up
you can look it up on your phone it says
medical definition the administration of
a drug to bring about a mark reduction
in the body's production of androgens
and especially testosterone and i'm
saying as a pediatrician
who takes care of hundreds of these kids
when you use that terminology
she's saying that if you use the actual
definition you're being malignant and
harmful yeah they're trying to change
definitions
the audacity of these people you think
you have you have the power to change a
word it's the victimhood though yeah
yeah it's like i'm gonna have a normal
conversation with you and as soon as you
ask me a tough question i'm gonna play a
victim oh my god like that's really bad
oh sorry that's really bad oh no i
agreed to this interview and he's asking
tough question like what the [ __ ] what
did you think
was gonna happen
this is what we do
we get paid to argue what are you people
people people like this is the way the
world is going i'm so glad that we have
an outlet to actually just like what if
what are we saying what if we had to
just sit at home and not tell the world
and not say anything and just watch it
just crumble as we're just sitting at
home no way no way i
yeah thank god for youtube thanks for
listening guys i love complaining about
these people on camera
say that giving
chemical castration drugs to kids is
malignant and harmful it's about the
context of caring for a child and and
seeing the
the suffering that kids can have that
have not been in affirmative home
situations
so we're going on this journey
boys can be girls girls can be boys
men can be women women can be men
it makes me wonder
[Music]
what is a woman
what is a woman a woman is someone who
claims that is their identity
i'm a woman
i claim female and woman as my identity
as you can see i am
i'm a man
i'm a fine ass man i'm a fine woman
apparently you know what i mean humble
yourself
is it possible i can be a specific woman
so can i be rihanna
i bet you could i mean that can i be i
want to say
[ __ ]
who could i be
you could be
oh i could be will smith i'll leave
jaden
i'll do it for you i'll be jailer i'll
try and keep you okay where you going
boy
but it's like these people are crazy i
don't under
and it's just crazy because i don't
think that we should be like
we shouldn't have to say this stuff no a
common sense should be common but like i
said common sense is definitely not
common amongst these people no it's not
no and um
like we've already said like oh you know
facts don't care about your feelings but
clearly we're living in a world now
where
feelings trump facts do you think she's
married
if she is she's probably married to a
woman
whatever she is married to i feel like
this is what happens when women are
single too long
i feel like this is what happens when
feminism takes over the world yeah that
too
but what are feminists they'd be lonely
come on
that was our answer well a woman is
anyone and that was by the way not to
give any spoilers away but
that is
the answer
from the left to the question which is a
non-answer it's the same thing as not
answering at all but that is that is the
answer the woman is someone who says
everyone
and of course to everyone who gives me
that answer in the film i have the
follow-up well a woman is someone who
identifies as a woman what are they
identifying as and around and around we
go
because they don't have an answer to the
question
this is a
medical doctor
who can't tell you what a woman is
i mean this is someone who who
if someone goes to her and says as a man
and says you know i'm really a woman i
want to transition into a woman
she will help facilitate that process
and yet she doesn't know what the word
means
she doesn't actually know she by her own
testimony
when someone says i want to transition
to a woman she doesn't even know what
that means like what are you
transitioning into
she has no idea
wow wow wow wow
oh my gosh
i can't believe people like that example
a doctor
a doctor i need to see the film was when
you were in because you're an actor yeah
when you're
acting like full-time or whatever
did were there a lot of crazies in
acting
there were a lot of flamboyant
like we call them la dee da people you
know
and everything's
yeah like i wouldn't say crazy i would
say like
creative oh okay and sometimes that
creativeness could go into a place yeah
which is why they take so much [ __ ]
drugs as well like
oh do think oh my god i'm telling you
the first time i started acting right
remember i'm i'm coming from
before the age of i got into acting when
i was in my teens okay
i
had never i'd been around people i've
sold drugs and been around people that
had smoked weed okay
i had never smoked or drunk in my life
until i hit the age of like 27. oh
really well yeah so i went to
into this world
i was told tea talk within a drink and
smoke yeah yeah and when i got into that
world
the way people took cocaine mm-hmm
oh what coke coke
they would have you see your water
yeah offer it to you like glass water oh
really i hate you want to join atlanta
oh wow how would i
no
i've only found that with finance people
like my friends from college that went
into finance
they would always be the ones at the
party doing pokes
and then us normal people were just like
ah
i'd never seen it before i'm not gonna
lie i was it was kind of like a shock to
me
and then some of the people that i got
quite close with in the acting world
were like you know onto it i can't be
around well i was i was just wondering
because i it seems like the creatives
seem to have more like left in them
but that's why i i don't see a lot of
super left people in medicine
because usually it's usually rooted in
reality yeah yeah yeah that's right so
how did this woman make it through
medical school like how did she answer
her exams
it's my question
when that's a good question yeah like to
be a pediatrician
you have to
treat children
so there are boys and girls
so how did she get past maybe she
started it
and then changed her mind at some point
maybe yeah maybe because she it's she's
old so yeah
oh my gosh that was that's literally
nuts
um well any final thoughts about the
video
um
[Music]
um i just think that people in general
need to start living in reality i think
you know
i know it sounds it sounds really easy
you know yeah yeah it sounds really easy
but for some people it's just not easy
enough like it's hard i don't know
no i agree like i think
and i think that it's also around the
people around them for letting them live
in indonesia that's why that's why
you're great on the show
you know you don't want these hoes no i
don't i don't let
i speak my mind and i'm quite firm yeah
it rubs people the wrong way but
yeah i can't change yeah yeah so my dm's
are still cold
i'm just saying